con 72 votos a favor 37 56 extensiones
El Congreso de chile lava luz verde a la
renovación por novena B del estado de
extensión que rige desde el pasado 13 de
octubre es la llamada Macro zona Sur es
decir varias provincias de la región del
biobío y de la
araucaníamos kilómetros
de defensa producica el hecho de que se
instale el estado de excepción en la
zona ha permitido reducir en un 47% los
incidentes de violencia ya son 72% la
toma de terrenos ilegales esto justifica
la prolongación de este estado de
extensión que no es querido por todas
las personas en el país
el próximo 11 de marzo en el que entra
en el poder el nuevo presidente electo
Gabriel
a este estado
por la escalada violencia intensa que se
ha vivido en la zona donde es frecuente
en los ataques a empresas forestales y
también a sus trabajadores el último de
estos ataques se registraba el pasado
lunes con el fallecimiento de dos
trabajadores de una empresa Forest